[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
para ello ya está conmigo en el estudio
jorge hurtado jorge muy buen día feliz
lunes para ti vamos a empezar hablando
de la economía en eeuu así decides que
la secretaria del tesoro de eeuu janet
yellen aseguró ayer en una entrevista
que la inflación o el aumento de los
precios se va a mantener inclusive hasta
mediados de
2022 pese a la preocupación sobre una de
las principales economías del mundo la
funcionaria rechazó que eeuu corre el
riesgo de perder el control de la
inflación
yellen adjudica la inflación a los
cuellos de botella en la cadena de
suministros a las deficiencias en el
mercado laboral y otras consecuencias de
la pandemia
helen conversó ayer con cnn aseguró que
la situación actual refleja un dolor
temporal pero el viernes el presidente
de la reserva jermaine power expresó
también su preocupación respecto al tema
de la inflación en ese país se agregó
que el banco central va a comenzar a
reducir sus compras de bonos en
noviembre
eeuu registró su segundo déficit
presupuestario anual más grande en 2021
durante la pandemia el gasto social raúl
aumentó y elevó el nivel de
endeudamiento del gobierno
el índice de precios al consumidor de
estados unidos subió un 0.4 por ciento
de septiembre y colocó la inflación
anual al 5,4 por ciento una décima más
que en el mes anterior y es el nivel más
alto en 13 años seguimos a en américa
jorge en brasil altos funcionarios del
ministerio de economía
renunciaron esto bueno lo hicieron
precisamente por en conformidad con
algunas medidas que está tomando el
gobierno de el bolsón ya bolsón área
específicamente algunas maniobras
respecto al gasto en 2022 cuando el país
va a celebrar elecciones el secretario
especial del tesoro y presupuesto bruno
funchal y el secretario del tesoro
nacional jefferson betancourt eran los
principales responsables por las medidas
para impedir un aumento de déficit en
las cuentas públicas brasileñas el
ministro de economía había dicho antes
que revisaba la forma de financiar el
gasto social y entre ellas estaba pues
subir el techo de la deuda del plan de
bolsonaro que es dar subsidio a los más
pobres y darlo a más familias
beneficiadas de 14 mil de 14,7 millones
de personas hasta 17 millones así como
aumentar en un 20% el valor de las
ayudas hasta un mínimo de 400 reales
mensuales que son aproximadamente unos
70 dólares por familia este plan
representaría un alivio para muchas
familias de brasil por la situación
económica pero podría aumentar el precio
de los alimentos el programa social
también costará unos 5 mil 300 millones
de dólares al gobierno la inflación allí
se ubica en 8,45 por ciento y el
controversial plan será anunciado
probablemente esta semana por una
noticia en desarrollo que se viene
presentando en sudán los militares pues
se tratan de tomar completamente el
poder de esa nación africana vamos a
darle seguimiento a lo que está pasando
allí pero por supuesto con un enfoque
económico así es bueno sudán sudán vive
un agravada crisis económica que es
legado de décadas de mala gestión
económica abajo el ex presidente omar al
bachir de hecho raúl los problemas
financieros y el aumento de los precios
de los alimentos fueron el detonante de
las protestas masivas contra el bayern
derrocado en 2019 en los últimos tres
años el gobierno había intentado
reformar la economía con sugerencias de
los organismos financieros
internacionales y estas sugerencias eran
por ejemplo eliminar el subsidio de
combustible y aplicar o tratar de apagar
en el mercado negro que existe ahí las
cifras de inflacionaria llegaron a un
punto máximo en julio pasado de más del
40 422 por ciento luego caído en agosto
al 388 por ciento y registro
365 por ciento en septiembre varias
naciones del mundo han prometido ayuda
para asistir humanitariamente a ese país
cuya economía depende de las
exportaciones de petróleo de hecho
durante el último mes los manifestantes
molestos con el gobierno bloquearon los
accesos al puerto afectando los ingresos
estatales unos 1.200 contenedores
diarios pasan por ese puerto que
representa alrededor del 60 por ciento
del comercio del país ya productos como
el trigo y la gasolina se están agotando
allí y parece que la crisis se va a
agravar con este nuevo conflicto
político lamentable jorge lo que pasa en
sudán ahora le pregunto por los
indicadores económicos comenzamos en
asia donde las acciones en india por
ejemplo cerraron prácticamente sin
cambios debido a que las pérdidas en las
acciones del sector automotriz y la
tecnología se vieron compensadas por las
ganancias en los bancos las acciones
europeas subieron con la energía la
salud y las finanzas es liderando todas
las ganancias jorge pues gracias por
toda la información la cifra el día para
el segundo bloque económico vamos ahora
a ver nuestro reportaje del día le
parece vamos a verlo
[Música]